[Music]
I want people to feel emotion because
when art until the moment of caring it
allows people to connect to an issue
that there are otherwise not sensitive
to it and that allows them to change the
inner attitude because who you are on
the inside is how do you express outside
to do not even aware and you're not
thinking about the things that are
happening the world around us if you're
not educated they're not likely to
change your behavior I decided to use
bottles because of this unifying motif I
decided to use what is ephemeral to be
timeless I started my career in fashion
designing I went to school right here on
seventh Avenue at Parsons and then began
working at various well-known fashion
houses but I realized very quickly on
that it was not my passion to be in
fashion and in true explorer spirit I
decided to step out of those boundaries
and explore and what was not a comfort
zone to me I went out into the wild I
started looking at what was happening to
the world around us because if the
consumer choices where we're making so I
went from an industry that's a lot about
promoting consumerism to path of life
that makes me question every single
choice I make
[Music]
every time you pull your wallet out
you're changing the way the love is and
you can change it for the better but you
can change
[Music]
[Music]